5 jours après la disparition du Titan et
de ses cinq passagers les réserves
d'oxygène pourraient s’épuiser
rapidement puisque l'hypothétique
autonomie de respirable en plongée était
de 96 heures c'est 24 heures à venir
centrer décisives mais qui est encore
une possibilité de les trouver non
l'histoire de de plonger sur le Titanic
moi j'ai failli y aller donc bien au
courant de l'opération l'après en fait
c'est une mascarade américaine de
l'armée américaine qui était à la
recherche des epaves des sous-marins
soviétiques encore une victime dans le
prêt-à-porter la marque jennifer est à
son tour placé en redressement
judiciaire les Américains se sont cachés
derrière un programme d'exploration
scientifique au nez la barbe et la
France a été associée à cela sans savoir
au départ
ce robot sous-marin Canadien a découvert
un champ de débris par 3800 mètres de
fond à proximité de l'épave du Titanic
selon un proche de deux passagers il
pourrait correspondre à des pièces du
dessous et de l'arrière du submersible
disparu le périmètre est toujours bouclé
sans mettre autour du 277 rue
Saint-Jacques tôt dans la matinée les
enquêteurs de la police judiciaire ont
réalisé les premières constatations sur
place j'ai un doute sur le gars
et oui
de gaz avant il y a pas de témoignages
il y a pas eu de travaux de récent et
donc Saint-Jacques et là on se dit voilà
vous n'excluez pas par exemple quelque
chose de criminel explosion en plein
Paris des images qui en rappellent
d'autres et notamment celle d'il y a 4
ans rue de Trévise 4 morts à l'époque
dont deux pompiers et 66 blessés c'est
bien le gaz qui était alors en cause
avec une canalisation défectueux sous le
trottoir devant l'immeuble cet immeuble
Abritel à Paris American Academy une
école privée de design avant l'explosion
cet ancien pavillon d'entrée de l'abbaye
du Val De Grasse classé monument
historique présentait vous le voyez de
hautes fenêtres aujourd'hui à sa place
un tas de pierres et de bois donc
apparemment en fonction de ce qui est
dit si c'est vrai il y avait pas il y
avait le gaz qui était distribué dans la
rue mais il y avait plus la colonne
montante c'est-à-dire la distribution
dans l'école ça c'est troublant
objectifs des soulèvements de la terre
n'acceptent pas sa dissolution annoncée
hier en conseil des ministres plusieurs
cortèges se sont réunis hier soir pour
protester contre la décision du
gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
il est environ 20h30 dans le quartier de
la Colombette à Toulouse lorsque le
maire de la ville est 4 de ses élus se
font agresser par un robot ultra gauche
[Musique]
c'est ça donc moi je suis contre la
violence de toute manière ce qui se
passe à Toulouse j'ai pas suivi ça a eu
lieu cette nuit c'est inacceptable et il
va de soi que personne ne doit être pris
à partie ils ont pris des poubelles qui
étaient à proximité ils les ont ouvertes
et nous ont balancé des projectiles des
ordures ménagères et aussi des
bouteilles espace médiatique ne parlera
pas de aujourd'hui de ce qui pourrait
pourtant être à la une de tous les
journaux mais ça ne correspond pas à
leur à la ligne de lecture ou à la
grille de lecture du moment énoncé vous
parler c'est la hausse des cambriolages
et de la violence une gigantesque
bagarre ou bilan terrible dans une
prison pour femme ou Honduras 46 détenus
sont mortes dans des affrontements entre
bandes rivales ce qu'on peut voir c'est
que c'est répressions se développent
partout dans le monde et on punit ceux
qui tire la sonnette d'alarme au lieu de
punir ceux qui crée et qui alimente le
feu sur la planète palmarès de la
délinquance des vins du petites villes
5000 à 20000 habitants les plus touchés
c'est le Figaro qui publie ça les
cambriolages les coûts et blessures hors
famille mais j'ai envie de dire c'est
pas le Figaro qui a fait l'enquête le
Figaro a pris les statistiques du
ministère de l'Intérieur ces
statistiques sont disponibles pour tous
les journalistes de France certaines ont
été brûlées vives d'autres ont succombé
à des blessures par balles des centaines
de proches des détenus se trouve à
proximité de la prison pour avoir des
informations vous le voyez la présidente
du pays réclame des comptes elle a
limogé son ministre de la Sécurité